after last night's game wanted to dial
up our friend who covers this
uh team and this sport in the city of
tampa from the tampa bay times rick
stroud back here on the show how are you
rick
how'd the buck lose this game well done
rick
very well done i'm doing well rich
my high register isn't going that high
yet but uh boy
um you know
they tom brady holding four fingers up
and not knowing
um you know what downer was clearly even
though bruce arians basically said today
well you'll have to ask him but we knew
what down it was
um you know just just as sort of the
the the 2020 season so far for him and
and it was it was unbelievable i mean he
had you know the ball with 248 to go in
the lead
they couldn't you know couldn't run any
clock then he had the ball again
um with plenty of time fourth and five
you know takes a shot down the field
doesn't know
what down it is i mean they've got a lot
of problems brady isn't really very high
on the list of them
um but uh but that's one that that you
know
they're gonna regret i think down the
road and we'll see how much it hurts
them in the future but
it's a beat up football team rich and um
and yesterday was was not a good
performance by anybody including the
coaching staff
okay so there's a lot right there rick
let's take it let's take it one at a
time and i think you're
spot on that brady is not you know high
on the list of issues as to why this
team is three and two
that said i was you know
high on this team i still am i picked
them to win the super bowl
um because i thought that brady with
this offense
as it was constructed not just roster
wise but also
with left witch and aryans being of one
mind and body
and attitude that brady would be the
perfect vessel for it
but the fact that there was no on-field
workouts except for whatever tom was
doing on his own with players even
though they weren't supposed to
that it does look like they're out of
sync it does look like there is
just um they're still in some sort of
mode
despite the five touchdowns that we saw
last week what do you think rick
no you're absolutely right and and one
coach described it to me is every week
seems to be a jigsaw puzzle and what the
problem
right now has been really since the
start of the year you mentioned all the
things you know not
having the off season but it's injuries
you know
they haven't had a healthy mike evans
with a healthy chris godwin
now oj howard is gone for the year um
you know you had guys playing yesterday
that
um you know we're making their first
catches in the nfl you know
uh he's throwing to tyler johnson and
cyril grayson
and guys like this um you know it's been
a grab bag
and they they weathered it you know when
they were down 17 a week ago or on
sunday seems like a week ago on sunday
against the chargers
and they kind of made the adjustment
with him and byron left which at
halftime started attacking downfield and
made
huge plays and came back and won the
game but not everything was
was right in the first half right
obviously so
they're really struggling with um you
know sort of that
lack of continuity that they have you
know their identity on offense it looks
like they can run the ball a little bit
with ronald jones
but with so many injuries i mean you
know from
shady mccoy and leonard fournette not
really playing and god when we mentioned
you know scotty miller was out there
yesterday didn't get a target didn't
make sense
so i i think there needs to be you know
more time more meeting of the minds and
you know eventually they'll get it
ironed out but
the other part of this is that the
culture of this football team
i mean you know they led the league in
penalties last year
and they're right back there again and
you can't win games
with dumb football players i hate to say
it that way but it's true
and tom brady comes from a place where
they didn't suffer that for 20 seasons
and now
he's going to figure out why this
franchise whatever reason has
you know has a 387 lifetime winning
percentage i mean
you know these guys have to play more
discipline and they haven't done it
yeah i i you know that was being
discussed um
almost as much as the fourth down and
the fact that brady
left foles hanging for a handshake after
the game was brady on the sideline of
the game
um being very demonstrative as we're
used to seeing him when
something's not happening properly on
the field that was in fact about
the penalties and that one drive where
there seemed to be more flags than an
amusement park
for the for the uh bucks is that what it
was rick
absolutely yeah it was i think they had
55 yards of penalties not all of them
accepted
but that's what the total was i believe
and you know including after the whistle
things with head butts and ryan jensen
and you know that that sort of thing
just is intolerable
you know and you're gonna you're gonna
have some bad calls you know i mean look
they you know they had a catch
ruled not a catch that would have made
maybe been a touchdown and may have
changed that game
um they ended up with a field goal but
you know the things you can control
um and it's the it's you know what it's
also the higher price guy i mean these
are
you know donovan smith makes 14 and a
half million dollars he had you know two
false starts and a holding penalty and
gave up a couple sacks um
you know mike evans got into some post
you know post whistle stuff
ryan jensen same thing i mean you expect
your leaders as
you know coaches tell me that to play
and set the example and be the guys
um that are being disciplined so that
the younger players follow
and that's not happening right now and i
think i think brady
you know is going to continue to yell at
them and should
um but we'll see if if him alone and the
coaching staff can change that
rick stroud tampa bay times here on the
rich eisen show
um when when the winds happen it's all
great and you know aryan says no i'm
sorry so aryans is like we would have
lost that game
last year by 20 and brady's here and
it's great and then
the games in which they lose were we're
talking about
in game one uh after which he
uh said about brady that one of the
interceptions was on him
after which he basically said it wasn't
and now today you're saying you got to
ask tom we all knew
it was fourth down um right
do you think there's gonna be any there
there about again aryans and brady or
everything truly is
as you know expected there what what can
you tell us what's the temperature on
that through five games
it's it's a great it's a great question
and i i don't have a great answer i i've
talked to coaches
you know about the the comments bruce
made about the pick six and things like
that and
they tell me brady in in the building at
least never really brought it up
if he was bothered by it we asked him
and he seemed rather you know
rather annoyed maybe by the question or
whatever but
um clearly you don't like that i mean he
didn't get called out
you know by bill belichick at least
publicly
and and we know he did it behind closed
doors overall tom's happy here
overall i think this is a breath of
fresh air for him i think he feels like
he can breathe and
and he's got a lot of reasons why he
came to tampa but we know the number
one is to win and um you know
it's a new coach and and aryans is
different and
you get the good with the bad i mean
he'll call all kinds of players out
you know in the media sometimes he'll
he'll do it and then go
to them and say hey i just ripped your
ass you know
you know tell him after after the press
conference and so that's sort of who he
is
and i think you know brady would have
researched that and talked to peyton
manning and ben roethlisberger and
carson bomber would have known that
um by the same token you don't enjoy it
so
you know he's going to let tom have to
answer for this one and frankly tom had
two chances last night
and didn't address it i mean it was
great blocking bridge time for him but
he
he just sort of you know well i i you
know probably should have gone for the
first down you know went for too much
but he never but but i mean come on when
you listen you know but if you have to
choose between the audio and the video
believe the video so
let's let's also hit gronk here too rick
is while we're talking about new
situations for patriots on this team
uh first two weeks he he is even joking
he was there to block
uh he has been targeted much more and
has had
some uh receptions to the point it does
look like he's alive and he is part of
this offense in a manner
uh that that uh that is significant uh
my gronk
uh whisperer across the way a long time
patriot fan and chris brockman does not
see the same guy in terms of speed and
certainly enthusiasm like the guy that
would just
uh soak it all in i know there's no fans
in the stands and things of that nature
but what are you seeing at a gronk is he
not the same is he getting along coming
along what's the status with him and the
way people are observing it
i mean i think it's a fair observation i
mean you know he took a year out of
football
and i think he thought he was done i
think those keys were on the table
you know and you don't normally pick
them back up i've talked to
you know his dad uh gordy and he said
that he felt like tom
talked gronk back into playing again and
i mean that
that could well be you know and i again
when you see when you see gronk every
day and you see him in practice he's
having fun
you know what i mean he's not it's not
he's not moping around or anything
he likes being with the guys he likes
being with tom he likes he likes
football he loves football
but is he the same athlete is he
does he have the same quick twitch can
he get separation
i haven't seen it you know i mean you
gotta again believe the video i mean
i can't believe that tom brady wouldn't
throw him the ball if he
if he was winning if you know if the
coverage took him there
um he has more faith and and thrown more
passes to gronk than anybody
so you know i think it's a combination
of things
uh he's he's learning too you know this
offense is new for him
they've never featured the tight end in
this offense really you get some big
plays
some big seam routes and things like
that but it's never been
a high targeted um position
for bruce arians so all of that mixed in
is sort of where we're at with gronk
right
and um you know the main thing is is
that they need them to play tight end
and they need them to block and they
need them to do these things
because you know so with the injuries
they've had suddenly he's even more
valuable than
than when they got him when he was kind
of a luxury piece rick stroud tampa bay
times two minutes left with him
uh here on the rich eisen show okay rick
so next up
uh only the the the curve only gets
steeper um not just because the national
television eye
is going to be glaring right on this
team from uh the next
four games two of them are sunday nights
and the other one is a monday night
and then next week is the only one
that's not in front of everybody but
it'll be most of the country
because in comes the undefeated green
bay packers
and their 12 and aaron rodgers playing
at a very
very high level and if you want to talk
about somebody who could take advantage
of the undisciplined
here's a guy who just beat the atlanta
falcons by getting them to jump offsides
with a hard count
using the actual words hard count as his
heart count
so what do you think is
in fact the challenge facing this tampa
bay team for that one
it's enormous um now you know i've done
this enough and you have two rich that
you know it's an every week league right
i mean it's crisis or carnival when you
lose
you may not win another game and when
you win you could win the super bowl so
here come the green bay packers you're
gonna have some fans in in raymond james
stadium but most they've had this year
maybe that'll help a little bit um but
this is a beat up football team the
worst thing that happened yesterday
really other than the loss yeah i mean
this defense has completely changed he's
out for the year with a broken ankle
you know and now you having domicon sue
the the offensive lines are going to
certainly shade to him that's going to
create more problems for jason pierre
that whole defensive front the
linebackers aren't going to be as free
and this is a high-powered offense
coming in here they got to continue to
find a way to stop the run they just
don't have anybody to replace them
and i i think they're going to struggle
a little bit but
you know 10 days you get to rest some of
those injuries
they got to get healthy that's the main
thing can they get chris godwin back
can mike evans heal that ankle um can
they can they you know clean up some of
these penalties in the offensive line
play better
so it's not it's not all doom and gloom
but you're right those
those next games are on national tv the
spotlight is on them
and they start with the packers and they
end that gauntlet with the new orleans
saints so
this is their season right in front of
them well in terms of that rick
um what about godwin and fournette uh do
we
do we expect to get them back full i
know fournette was active last night but
he
you know he kind of had he had he kind
of had a malcolm butler
activeness you know from a super bowl a
couple years ago you're wondering why is
this person active if we don't see them
so uh what about what about the injuries
of players who aren't out for the season
for that one as we currently yeah was
the break break class in case of an
emergency running back and right and i i
think godwin will make it he's not going
to try to run till thursday
but i do think there's a really good
chance that he plays mike has played
hurt or not hurt so 10 days off will
certainly help him
problem is you can't practice right and
guys don't practice they're not as sharp
i think fournette since he was in
uniform will be in uniform again
maybe have you know more to do although
ronald jones is taking over at that
position a little bit
um so they'll get some guys back so
that's that's the important thing
and then i guess too rick just to wrap
it up when you know
uh as as the fault line that we're
seeing here
certainly on last night and it's just
one game i get it
but the fault line that we're seeing
here is that with aaron rodgers coming
in at 4-0 for green bay
into tampa this is one of those games
where
brady and the patriots would know okay
game on and we've got to be at our best
but we're one of the best
and we're gonna we're gonna make sure
that we're situationally smart
as we need to be against this guy and
we're going to be great on offense
because we know we can't make any
mistakes because of this other guy
rarely makes any and they raise their
game up and it's one of those
you know heavyweight slobber knockers
that that that leaves us all thinking
this could be for
the conference later on i mean brady's
been in all those games but the rest of
these
teams the people on this team have not
and the question is is brady gonna bring
him along or is he gonna wind up barking
at him because they're not
matching it like that's the issue here
and this is one of those games that i
think
can provide the fault line to either get
get larger or maybe
fuse a little bit what do you think
yeah i think he's going to try to drag
them with him i think it's going to be a
a really you know
miserable couple of 10 days and i think
that's important for this young football
team yeah i really do
and he said it last night he goes you
know if you don't you know if
you're not carrying this with you
there's something wrong with you and
that offensive line had played well they
played horrible it's all on film they're
embarrassed they should be embarrassed
and i think you'll get their best effort
and i really do think that they can come
back
and and play the kind of football they
played at least the second half for most
of that game against the chargers so
you know all that has to happen here's
the thing you know the bears are really
good defense we haven't talked about
them right
you feel them when you're on the field
and i don't know that the packers are as
good
on defenses as the bears were so i think
they'll bounce back
i think you know the sun will maybe be
out and and they'll play their best game
and
and brady does know how to how to rise
the level for everybody so that's what
he's got to do
that's why he's here that's why they're
they pay them 50 million dollars so
let's see if he can do it
rick appreciate the time and the insight
and uh and the great conversation as
always we'll check uh we'll check in and
down the road
maybe after this gauntlet we'll check
back in with you
i don't reach any time
it's a very popular segment it's a very
popular segment
good job rick we do that next but uh hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here